Follow lane focus on facebook,
twitter,
and instagram.
Uh,
what should we do today?
Today?
Let's talk about Chinese.
No,
let's talk about written Chinese.
let's talk about classical Chinese or
maybe standard Chinese.
No,
no.
We're going to talk about various
Chinese dialects.
Okay.
Let's just talk about all of them.
Hello everyone.
Welcome to the Lange Focus Channel and
my name is Paul.
Today we're going to talk about Chinese,
but the big question is what do I mean
when I say Chinese?
The word Chinese refers to standard
Chinese,
which is based on Mandarin,
but it also refers to a large group of
languages and dialects spoken throughout
China and indeed throughout the world.
Chinese languages also called synetic
languages or a sub family of the silo.
Tibetan language family.
Chinese is not a single language,
but rather a number of related dialect
groups which are united by a common
written language,
a common writing system.
Some people consider them all Chinese
dialects,
but I'm going to refer to these dialect
groups as distinct languages because in
many cases they are unintelligible.
All Chinese languages are tonal
languages.
The meaning of a word depends on the
tone or the tones that you say it with.
Sure.
She Shit,
if you change the tone,
the meaning of the word changes,
there were more than 1.3
billion native speakers of Chinese.
If we include all its varieties.
Standard Chinese generally referred to
as Mandarin is the official language of
the People's Republic of China,
the Republic of China,
also known as Taiwan or Chinese.
Taipei.
Okay.
And it's one of the four official
languages of Singapore.
Chinese languages are also spoken in
lots of diaspora communities throughout
Asia,
like in Malaysia,
Indonesia and Thailand and in different
communities around the world.
History,
the sign nick languages or the Chinese
languages developed from Prodo Sino
Tibetan,
which existed perhaps around 4,000
bce.
The earliest written examples of Chinese
are from around 1250 bce.
They were written using a form of
Chinese called the oracle bone script,
which was carved onto turtle shells and
animal bones,
which were used for divination,
like a kind of fortune telling,
a more recognizable form of old Chinese
developed during the Jo Dynasty between
10:46
AM two 56 bce.
It can be found on bronze sculptures
from that time period as well as in some
literature like a classic of poetry.
It's generally thought that during this
early time period Chinese had not yet
developed tones.
Those develops later in the transition
to middle Chinese,
the form of written Chinese that
developed between this period and the
end of the Han Dynasty in the third
century.
Ce is known as classical Chinese or
literary Chinese.
Classical Chinese continued to be used
as the formal written language until the
beginning of the 20th century spoken.
Chinese continued to evolve into middle
Chinese.
Middle Chinese is ancestor of almost all
modern Chinese varieties.
The exception is Min Chinese,
which developed earlier maybe during the
Han period.
Middle Chinese was not a single unified
language,
but consisted of a number of mutually
intelligible dialects that began
diverging in different directions around
the 10th century Ce,
and you'll probably hear me say that
every time I talk about a language
family,
those local varieties of Chinese
continued to develop in their own
directions as distinct languages over
the centuries with a lot of local
dialectal variation within each
language.
As I mentioned before,
classical Chinese was being used as the
formal written language,
but during this time period written
vernacular,
Chinese also developed alongside it,
written for an ocular Chinese refers to
ways of writing Chinese that reflect the
spoken language in its different
varieties.
These forms of Chinese were used for
some informal writing.
People were already writing and written
vernacular,
Chinese during the tongue and some
dynasties from the seventh to 13th
century CE,
old Mandarin.
After the Northern Song Dynasty and
during the gene and you end dynasties,
a language recognizable as a form of
mentoring was spoken.
This variety of Chinese is known as Old
Mandarin.
The UN dynasty was a period of Mongol
control of China.
The world's leading up to the Mongol
conquest caused large scale migration of
old mandarin speakers to the south.
This spread early mandarin dialects to
more areas and also had an influence on
other emerging Chinese languages.
Middle Mandarin during the Ming and
Ching dynasties and official
administrative language was created
based on the mandarin dialect of the
capitol non Jean with some features of
other dialects as well.
This was the first point at which the
language became referred to as Mandarin,
which means speech of officials.
We now refer to the stage of the
language as middle mandarin in the late
19th century towards the end of the
Ching Dynasty.
The specific dialect of Beijing started
to grow in importance and became the new
high variety of Chinese replacing the
older high variety which was based on a
number of different dialects at the
beginning of the 20th century,
a form of written vernacular,
Chinese based on a number of mandarin
dialects was introduced as the new
official written language instead of
classical Chinese,
but it was later decided that the new
official language should be based
specifically on the Beijing dialect.
This new standard language was called,
which means common language or which
means national language.
People often refer to this standard
language as mandarin because it's based
on the mandarin dialect of Beijing.
But to be precise,
the word mandarin refers to a range of
northern dialect.
Standard Chinese or Mandarin now
fulfills the role that classical Chinese
used to fulfill as the official written
language that's used by speakers of all
varieties of Chinese for most purposes,
but written vernacular languages still
do exist and are used for some informal
situations.
So how many varieties of Chinese are
there?
Well,
that depends on how you're counting and
categorizing them,
but it's often said that there are over
200 distinct varieties of Chinese,
which comprise around 13 distinct
dialect can groups the local dialects
within each of these groups are often
intelligible.
So it's reasonable to consider these
groups as languages at least I think so.
Out of these 13 groups of dialects,
there are seven that are generally
considered a major.
These are mandarin UAA Shung men by done
gone.
You
and hot got,
Huh?
The writing system,
Chinese is written in Chinese characters
or Hudson Han.
Soo are logograms single characters that
represent entire words or entire units
of meaning.
For example,
this character means China.
In this character means character as in
a written character and together they
mean Chinese character or Han Zu,
the kind we're talking about.
These characters need to be learned one
by one because just knowing the
pronunciation of a word doesn't give you
any indication of how to write it.
Speakers of all varieties of Chinese
typically right in standard Chinese or
mandarin,
even though their spoken language is
different when the reading standard
Chinese out loud,
they'll probably pronounce each
character the way it's pronounced in
their local variety of Chinese.
This has led to the common misconception
that all Chinese languages are exactly
the same except for their pronunciation.
The fact is Chinese languages often
differ in grammar and vocabulary as well
as pronunciation.
The various forms of written vernacular,
Chinese that developed alongside
classical Chinese still exist today
alongside standard Chinese.
They're only used in some limited
situations,
but Cantonese in particular is fairly
widely used from what I understand most
of the characters used are the same,
but there'll be pronounced differently
and some different characters might be
used to represent the different
vocabulary and the order of the
characters might be different to
represent the different syntax.
Pronunciation,
as previously mentioned,
Chinese languages are tonal.
That means that tones are one part of
the pronunciation that can change the
meaning of a word.
The same written word can be pronounced
very differently in different Chinese
languages.
This is the word for telephone first in
Mandarin,
next in Cantonese in Wa,
in Shanghainese,
and then Haka.
Let me explain a little further.
Mandarin has four main tones plus one
neutral tone.
The tones are number one,
a high flat tone to arising tone,
three uh,
falling.
Rising tone for uh,
falling tone and five,
the neutral tone,
meaning that syllable is not
distinguished by tone at all.
Ma Ma,
Ma,
ma.
Now Cantonese has six tones.
The six cantor.
These tones are number one,
a high flat tone to amid rising tome
three amid flat tone for a low falling
tone.
Five a low rising tone and six a low
flat tone.
Si,
Si.
Shanghainese has a different type of
tone system entirely.
It's more of a pitch accent system like
Japanese.
There were really only two tones high
and low.
At the tone of the first syllable
determines the tone pattern of the
following syllables.
The you hear,
the first syllable has a low tone,
which depends on the character that
makes the second syllable high and it
doesn't matter what character it is.
Tone is only connected to meaning in the
first syllable word order.
There are both similarities and
differences in the word order of Chinese
languages.
Mandarin is generally svo though it's
Sov and some structures and Cantonese is
also Svo more so than member
Shanghainese and other Wu dialects are
both Svo and Sov.
So in Mandarin we have who?
Courtroom,
which means I drink juice.
Here's the subject,
verb and object.
And in Cantonese,
all young goal,
it's up again,
subject,
verb,
object.
And now in Shanghainese.
Ooh,
took in these examples,
it turns out that the word orders the
same,
but notice that each language uses a
different character for the verb to
reflect different vocabulary.
Let's look at another element of word
order mandarin places an indirect object
before the direct object.
Cantonese places at after the direct
object like in this sentence,
which means give me the book in
Mandarin,
Gay Weapons.
So we're forward.
It's give me book and in Cantonese bape
and the single word for word,
it's give book me and a few.
Imagine a two in there.
It's like give book to me.
Also noticed the character for give is
different here and in Shanghainese oh
bones hear the word order is like
mandarin,
but notice the different word for give
and the variant character for me.
Another example of difference mandarin
or standard Chinese places.
The adverb before the verb.
This sentence means I'll go first in
member in it,
boy,
since all word for word,
it's I first go,
but Cantonese places,
the adverb after the verb,
all it's llc work forward.
It's I go first and in Shanghainese
we'll see about tele here.
The main word order is the same as
mandarin with the advert before the
verb,
but notice the additional particles at
the end which are four exclamation but
don't have any core meaning.
Another example difference mandarin
places,
the adjective after the noun,
so the phrase meaning strong wind in
Mandarin.
It's literally when the strong from how
Cantonese places the adjective before
the noun,
so literally it's strong wind hold
iphone and in Shanghainese Fun loud to
hear the adjective comes after the now
just like in Mandarin,
but notice that one of the two
characters is different.
Those are just a few samples of the
variation between the different Chinese
languages and their dialects.
We could go very deeply into these
differences,
but that's beyond the scope of this
general video.
One other difference we should talk
about though is that there are two
different systems for writing Chinese
characters.
There are traditional characters,
the ones that are written as they
weren't in classical Chinese and then
there are simplified characters which
were created in the 1950s and sixties to
increase literacy.
Simplified characters are used in the
People's Republic of China and in
Singapore.
Traditional characters are used in
Taiwan and in Hong Kong and Macau which
were not under Chinese rule.
When simplified characters were
introduced.
There are also used in many Chinese
diaspora communities.
Here's the traditional character on the
left and here's that.
Simplify the equivalent on the right so
you can see that they are different and
it's probably easier to write the
simplified loan,
but despite the differences,
literate native speakers generally have
no trouble reading either type of
character.
As you can see,
the scientific language family,
which is often called Chinese,
is a large diverse group of languages
and dialects which are often
unintelligible.
What unites them all together is there
shared origin and growing out of middle
Chinese and the classical Chinese
literary tradition,
and there are also united by a common
written language which is learned and
understood by speakers of all Chinese
varieties.
However,
even though speakers of different
Chinese languages can easily communicate
with each other in writing,
that shared writing system isn't enough
to help them communicate verbally
without specifically learning Mandarin.
This is a good reason to consider
Chinese a group of languages or a
language family rather than a single
language with many dialects.
Solve the question of the day to native
speakers of any variety of Chinese.
Do you consider Chinese to be a group of
distinct languages or do you consider it
one language with a lot of dialectal
variation?
And I'm just asking you to explain the
way that you personally think about it.
So there's no right or wrong answer
here.
And for people who have studied any
variety of Chinese,
just tell us something that you've found
fascinating about your journey with that
language.
Be sure to follow Lang,
focus on facebook,
twitter,
and instagram.
And once again,
I'd like to say thank you to all of my
fantastic patrion supporters,
especially these amazing people right
here on the screen.
Thank you for watching and have a nice.